here's a trivia question and i'm
informed that you will either know the
answer to this or you won't which
basically is typical of every trivia
question
right the titans are 5-0 for the second
time in franchise history the first was
obviously the 2008 team that christopher
david sims played for well
i used the term played loosely you threw
two passes that season completing one
who caught it man i don't know it wasn't
a pass
worth thinking about something short
i'm gonna go with a tight end seven
yards was the game i'm gonna
seven yards craig stevens is that by any
chance that
no boy you're gonna hear from paul
williams today
third round pick out of fresno state he
spent four years in the nfl
his only career catch his
he caught one pass in his career and you
don't remember it week 17 against the
colts he's now the receivers coach at
fresno city college
hello paul williams christopher has
forgotten you
but we have man paul is a great guy too
his name did go through my head i just
couldn't quite remember hey that was a
that was a big moment for me it really
was because that was the first time i
had played in a regular season game
since i lost my spleen and i'll i'll
forever be indebted to jeff fisher for
what he did for me that year
you know got me there really let me get
healthy i'd take a bullet for the guy i
really would and
you know that was like we've always
talked about that was a cool day too
because
you know yes the titans and of course
you're watching peyton manning and the
colts over there the other
that day and uh you know always cool to
see that rivalry but yeah
got got to play a little ball that day
well i guarantee you it wasn't a
touchdown pass no it was not that day
it was because the score was 23 nothing
indianapolis yes yeah it was i think
that means anything for the titans we
were already locked up home field so it
was like
you know we were one of those teams
where we kind of took the foot off the
gas pedal that last week and then we had
the bye
and we got caught sleeping a little bit
against the baltimore ravens
so was that your selling point to jeff
fisher let me play this week the game
doesn't mean anything no no no no they
they just threw me in there yeah i think
kerry played a little vince young got in
i believe and then i came in at the very
end
very end were you there with the was
2008 the year that things got really
weird with vince young was it that year
or the next year no it was that year was
it that was year that year yeah that was
an interesting year no doubt about it
you got you got some you got some
stories that you could probably tell we
need to take that up at some point
because that was a weird year and to get
the number one seed and to desecrate the
terrible towel and have it all fell
apart after that all right
match up draft i get the first pick i am
going to go with the obvious one derek
henry against the pittsburgh steelers
defense
yeah the immovable force wait what is it
see i've been around you too much
irresistible force versus the immovable
object
the it's the irresistible force and the
immovable object can derrick henry get
it done and
look i said this yesterday on football
pod in america and
we've talked about this it takes derek
henry a few steps to get going
that's when you have to get him if
you're the steelers you got to get him
you got to knock him down
you got every once in a while you see
him trying to bounce it outside and he
can't
get up to top gear and and that's what
you have to do if you won't have any
chance and we'll see if the steelers can
do it yeah
i mean that you're you're right this is
definitely one of the best ones of the
weekend that's steelers front seven
against those big mean
offensive linemen in the tennessee
titans and derek henry stinks taylor
lawan's hurt and he won't be there for
that but
uh that was definitely one of my top
picks too
i think the next one i'm gonna go do uh
is shanahan versus belichick
i i mean i'm really this is some game
with a lot of meaning
for two teams that are you know in
different conferences but
as we know the patriots are reeling a
little bit you know it seems like the
49ers are getting healthy and kind of
right
righted the ship a little to a degree
but where i'm really intrigued
we know the shanahan run scheme
everything he does there it's as
creative as it gets in football
belichick this great secondary but man
they don't have a lot of run stoppers
what is he gonna do to slow down this
49ers offense and some of the things
shanahan does to me
uh i i can't wait to kind of see the
chess match between those two guys
and like every other week this is one
where i had the same game i just had a
different matchup i go belichick jimmy
garoppolo because who knows jimmy
garoppolo
better than bill belichick and he
finally gets a chance to exploit
any and all weaknesses he may have
noticed during those years they were
together
next one for me kyler murray russell
wilson
round three a quarterback rivalry
involving a couple of guys who were
shorter than me although russell's
probably
my size kyle murray is definitely
shorter than me i love it when these two
guys get together
it should be explosive it should be fun
and
uh it's must-see tv on sunday afternoon
between the cardinals and the seahawks
i would think so i would think so and
you know of course we're going to see
some big plays from both of these guys i
mean russell wilson we know he's going
to deliver that way and this way the
seahawks defense is played
it doesn't sound like it doesn't sound
good for jamal adams and whether he'll
be ready to go because i don't think he
practiced at all
yesterday um to where i'm with you mike
i think you're going to see a lot of big
plays from both of these
quarterbacks no doubt all right i'm
going to go right he still hasn't jamal
still hasn't returned three and a half
weeks after the groin strain still not
practicing yeah that's
a tough one then they better take it
slow and make sure you know you don't
rush it to
re-aggravate it i'm gonna go to my old
coach yeah bucks
raiders you know that game right there
just the the meaning of the game in
general
gruden you know fired by the bucks took
them to a super bowl all those things
now he's back with his original team you
know i
i'm pretty sure he still has his house
in tampa florida
you know he grew up there i just know
this will be a personal
uh a personal match-up for him he'll
want to win this football game and of
course now he's dealing with the kova 19
and all that
and you know hey his legacy is probably
a little in danger here too the bucks
are looking damn good bruce arians maybe
he'll be the next coach in tampa to win
a super bowl so i just
i think that's an interesting matchup
for our sunday night game
absolutely a great game for sunday night
tom brady and company going to las vegas
to take on john gruden
the team that once traded him versus the
team that once fired him
he's now back with the team that traded
him and he's looking for his shot at
revenge
third round of the matchups draft i am
going with
and i've got three possibilities here
i'm going with ezekiel elliott versus
ezekiel elliott has he's got to get this
fumbling stuff out
of his head he's got to figure out what
he's doing wrong
he's got to fix it and he can't be
obsessing about it when they play
washington this weekend or he will
fumble more times chris
yeah pretty damn good defense too with
washington it won't be easy
and they're d-line you know in the
dallas o-line not being in a full
strength i mean i would think they're
going to make things hard on ezekiel
in the running game and try to make andy
dalton beat them we'll see where that
goes i think that's gonna that's an
interesting match up
i'm gonna go on the monday night
football game a little bit
you know just i i want to really say
i guess mcveigh versus chuck pagano
that's where i'll go
but mcveigh has not had the greatest
success against these three
four type of teams vic fangio and the
bears gave them
issues right a few years ago when they
played it's a similar scheme it's very
similar that way
and the one thing we've seen and this is
my big question with the rams if they
can't run the ball
can their offense really move it because
once they can't run they can't have
boots and the play actions aren't there
and their drop back pass game's a little
underwhelming so
i think that's going to be an
interesting matchup to you know
see who wins that football game i agree
with you one that i wanted to get to
yeah you know i'm out of rounds joe
brady versus dennis allen
the two saints assistants yeah brady was
there he killed the offense runs the
offense dennis allen knows it
let's see what happens when the three
and two or another three and three
panthers get together with the three and
two
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports